you
[Music]
when dinosaurs ruled the earth the
Tyrannosaurus Rex is believed to have
been the most feared predator but it
wasn't the biggest of the prehistoric
beasts meet the newly named Pat ago
Titan may Oram a study out this week
proclaims it's by far the largest
species of dinosaur
there's many advantages to being big it
helps these dinosaurs avoid predators
predators don't attack you if you're
that big a member of the aptly named
titanosaur family the pata go Titan
measured more than 120 feet from head to
tail nearly the length of a 737 and
weighed in at 72 tons about as much as
10 African elephants a fossil of the
dinosaur was first discovered in 2012 in
the Patagonia region of Argentina part
of its name may orem is derived from the
name of the family on whose land the
fossils were discovered and a cast of
the skeleton has resided in New York's
Museum of Natural History since last
year it's so big the head can't even fit
into the museum's dinosaur gallery the
Pedigo Titan here in the museum in New
York was not done fully growing we're
not totally sure how much bigger they've
gotten probably not much more but still
this is not you know the full size
potentially how to go take large and in
charge right there I love the name
titanosaur I love its heads sticking
through the door at the Museum right and
this weekend you can enjoy seeing it the
interesting thing too t-rex and this one
did not live at the same time so that's
why they were able to do they would have
that would have anyone interesting buddy
exactly